[Musique]
bruno domaine maire de saint-leu
accueilli le président du département
cyrille melchior pour la signature du
12e pacte de solidarité territoriale les
problèmes de saint leu ne sont pas les
mêmes que poêlé commune d'à côté et
chaque meilleur bas propose ses projets
en fonction de ses priorités
et ça pour moi c'est important
dans le domaine social d'autant plus que
par exemple nos gramounes ou à nos
jeunes et bien chaque maire fait des
propositions et pour le département nous
allons arriver par la suite a fait une
synthèse de ces propositions de façon à
voir que s'il ya des actions qui sont
menées à saint leu peut-être pour que
les étendre sur d'autres territoires du
département de la réunion et à ce moment
là le département pour à 20 da basse et
d'un spa d'un stade expérimental par
exemple à saint leu un sac plus
départementale un pacte signé pour la
période de 2018 à 2020 qui représentera
3 millions d'euros en investissement et
600000 euros au titre du volet social
c'est une vraie satisfaction de
d'avoir du département plus de 3
millions d'euros pour les équipements
tels que l'école père et fourcade et la
maison cartier de cap le lièvre 3
millions d'euros en investissement plus
de 600000 euros en fonctionnement
avantage de reparti travaux et c'est
qu'on fait déjà sur la ville le 5
donc c'est tard c'est une vraie
satisfaction est vraiment merci au
département qui nous donne vraiment un
élan donc avec la baisse des dotations
d'état
donc on retrouve cette bouffée d'oxygène
qui nous permettra de faire avancer et
corps un coup de sabre s'est ensuite
déroulée la présentation à l'école père
et fourcade du projet de modernisation
de cette école maternelle en école
primaire qui sera financée par le pacte
de solidarité territoriale
[Musique]